there's no such thing as a perfect job
and there's no such thing as a perfect
person
of course there are things that we are
doing that hold ourselves back and of
course there are things about the
environment in which we work whether
it's the people or the job or the
whatever the circumstances that may also
be holding us back i mean but to see
ourselves as victims is not is not the
uh is not the thing um but rather to
seek opportunity and and it goes back to
that growth mindset um uh which is it's
what i've learned is one of the best
ways to grow oneself is to actually help
somebody on the team grow
service
you know there's an entire section in
the bookshop called self-help and
there's no section in the bookshop
called help others and i think what
we've done is we've over indexed on the
whole rugged individualism sort of
self-help-y thing how can i be
successful how can i grow my business
how can i lose weight how can i find
love and yet we forget how can i help
somebody else
grow their business how can i help
somebody else find success how can i
help help somebody else lose weight and
find love etc and the irony is is the
more that we set out to help somebody
else because we have more objectivity
with other people ironically we actually
learn to help ourselves i i tried this
out i did a little experiment
a dear friend of mine
uh was going through a hard a hard time
um
a solopreneur um
work wasn't going well
her marriage was shaky and she was in a
bad place
and so she knows what i do for a living
so she called me up and says would you
spend some time with me i said of course
so every single week religiously we
spent about 90 minutes together she'd
come over and we would talk and i would
offer some perspective and some ideas
and she'd feel great for like a day or
two and then she'd go back and we'd get
together the next week and she'd feel
great for a couple of days and then go
back and this repeating pattern went on
for quite a while
and then i remembered
my own work which is the idea of service
and
had a little idea which is to switch to
switch it around and i called her up and
said look i would like some coaching too
and it was genuine i said you know me
better than anybody else i trust you
completely
when we get together
for one of our sessions
can it can i can i use up some of the
time can i tell you what i'm going
through
and what ended up happening is we spent
all 90 minutes
talking about my stuff
and this went week after week after week
where she was just the uh advice giver
and
strange things started to happen she
started to get more stability in her
work more stability to her marriage her
confidence went up and it was because
she was helping me
that she was gaining all the insights in
perspective because it wasn't
personalized it's like sales training
and anybody who's ever gone through
sales training you know this which is
you always do it with three people you
know the person who plays the role of
the salesperson the person who plays the
role of the uh the person you're selling
to the buyer and an observer and it's
the observer that does the learning not
the people playing the roles well in
this case she got to see herself not
being not be so close to gave her
objectivity so i'm a great believer in
if you have a problem to solve at work
try and help somebody else solve that
same problem